[Music]
it's starting to feel
a lot like 2010 again on twitch thanks
to the resurgence of one of the most
popular games of all time minecraft
but there's a catch a lot of these
twitch streamers aren't playing the game
the way you remember it they're not
starting a world in order to explore
build and survive or to enjoy the game
at a nice leisurely pace
oh my god you got a cow
no in fact they're doing the exact
opposite they're trying to rip through a
game that was never supposed to
end as fast as humanly possible
zoomers hell you always yeah okay final
screen 30 minute
lag on the dot
hey xqc every time i get down in my
feelings i always tune in
zoomers
okay well i almost didn't die
all right that was good practice
these days it seems like every popular
games lifespan
is kinda short one day everyone's raving
about fall guys
the next they've moved on to among us
but over the years one game in
particular has been able to withstand
the test of time
and that's minecraft it's been around
for 11 years and people still can't get
enough
with 126 million players logging into it
every month
this this game was always for little
kids and everybody on twitch used to
always make fun of it
until twitch became old enough that all
the little kids that we used to make fun
of are now like 18 and they call us
boomers so now
the 18 year old minecraft people like
lead us
and all the older people that used to
[ __ ] on it are just like oh i always
like that game
look at me i am one of those people but
on top of having a massive
player base minecraft boasts an equally
dedicated content hungry audience
across both youtube and twitch and
that's become especially apparent over
the last 12 months
while its resurgence started with many
streamers returning to the classic
adventurer mode
by the end of the year others had set
their sights on the brutally
unforgiving hardcore mode you didn't
tell me it exploded donator
[Music]
but today the newest minecraft craze on
twitch isn't to do with one of the
already established modes or
server-like skyblock it's with
speedrunning
and while minecraft speedrunning has
been a very niche thing since the
addition
of the end in december of 2016
it didn't become a spectacle until a
faceless youtuber by the name of dream
came along
the dream is one of the hottest content
creators on the planet having just
passed 12 million subscribers on his
channel in little over a year
back in july of 2019 his jump in
popularity began when he released a
string of videos attempting to figure
out pewdiepie's let's play minecraft
seed
yes that randomly generated number that
had over 18
quintillion possibilities this is the
team
that found that number just by watching
pewdiepie
from there dream released more and more
minecraft specific content with his most
popular videos
focusing on his speedrunning and insane
challenges
dream is such a god at the game that at
one point he even held the world record
for the glitchless any percent
random seed category you have 18 seconds
yes anyway midway through 2020 dream
expanded to twitch and started streaming
there with his friend and fellow
minecraft
juggernaut george not found and it
wasn't long before the two content kings
and their exploits began making some
serious waves
we cannot wiggle your hips there's sixty
thousand polluting here right now we can
do a really cool thing
if we all clap when i say
so let's just we can just do it and then
everyone's clapping
and in no time dream george and the rest
of their crew
caught the attention of twitch giants
like forzan through their insane
challenge videos
and crazy speed running antics that's by
dream not
dream
uh
all right uh that seems like an easy
enough record to break at one point
i'm not gonna lie now forzan is no
stranger to minecraft content
in fact just a couple months earlier he
spent countless hours trying to beat
hardcore mode
but the any percent random seed category
presented a new
challenge for him one that proved to be
harder than he could have
ever imagined loading
struggles caught the attention of clint
stevens who made it his mission to beat
the competitive swedes time and it
wasn't long before he passed on the
minecraft speedrunning bug
to ms kiffin simply would you want to do
a bet with me
and simply on seeing who can get under
an hour first
uh yeah sure i'll do that i'm trying to
be forsen
so we got to be forced in one of us and
of course a party just wouldn't be a
party without xqc getting involved on
the shenanigans
you know what else deserved as the days
went on
the dividing competition between all of
these streamers
became pretty apparent while clint took
a break from streaming and simply
dominated the pack
ms kiff brought up the rear after having
difficulties breaking one
hour it was a failure that cost him his
hair
it's such a shame that minecraft ruined
your personal best time on the
fair speed run this left only fours in
an xqc to go
toe to toe mono a mono one on one
in their bid for the minecraft
speedrunning crown
the [ __ ] dollars dude
oh my god i almost choked that
we're all out of juice but we have this
coke here
despite the tremendous heart shown by
both midway through october
it was xqc who finally pushed his limits
crushing forzan's record by 14 minutes
holy [ __ ]
for weeks xqc's record which he improved
to 32 minutes
stood uncontested run after run fors and
streams
had one simple goal get under half an
hour
and midway through november the madman
finally succeeded
30
[Music]
all the while baldkiff quietly continues
to grind in the background
desperately trying to get back into the
race between xqc
and forsen
it's been a couple of months since these
guys started doing this and
honestly there's no end in sight in fact
even more streamers are plopping a timer
down on their streams
as they follow in the footsteps of dream
11 years in and minecraft is still one
of the most
watched games on the planet and this is
exactly why
with guys like dream and george not
found continuing to
innovate and unearth new ways for people
to enjoy
minecraft the game remains as fresh and
addictive
as it did all those years ago and
honestly
that's not changing anytime soon
you